hitting around magnetic field in the
vicinity of Sagittarius a start the
process is called synchrotron emission
and basically as electrons are gyrating
around the magnetic field they emit
radiation because of their acceleration
synchrotron radiation and the frequency
of the radiation depends on their
Lorentz factor and the strength of the
magnetic field the theory for single
drone emission was developed the last
you know hundred years ago but the
details of how the magnetic field is
organized and what's responsible for
producing these relativistic electrons
is still unsettled for example these
relativistic electrons could be a result
of reconnection of magnetic fields like
we see in flares on the surface of the
Sun whenever you get to field lines that
are crossing each other they can
reconnect and release energy magnetic
energy in the by accelerating particles
to near the speed of light that's one
possible source another one is that when
electrons can ride on plasma waves
propagating and get accelerated to high
speeds the bottom line is or you can
have also shocks that are accelerating
by the Fermi mechanism a mechanism that
Enrico Fermi envisioned 50 years ago
based on the idea that then when you
have a shockwave you have convergence of
flows and if you go to the shock rest
frame you can see matter approaching you
from both directions and so when a
particle bounces back and forth due to
reflection by magnetic field
inhomogeneities it's as if you have a
tennis ball reflected from to
approaching racquets so when a tennis
ball is reflected bye-bye to approaching
racquets it gains momentum every time it
bounces and so particles can just gained
momentum a small fraction of the
particles have a probability of gaining
momentum and so you can calculate what
will be the end result of such a process
and you find that
you end up with a power-law distribution
of relativistic particles and so the
existence of sharks around Sagittarius a
star due to turbulence could also
accelerate electrons to high speeds and
the bottom line is we see the spectrum
of emission from Sagittarius a star and
we can describe it by a population power
low population of electrons together
with some strength for the magnetic
field and more the polarization gives us
additional constraints on the geometry
of the magnetic field because if you
have magnetic field that is coherent
then you end up with a very strong
polarization when you let a beam of
electrons orbit around it you can get a
very high level of polarization
depending on the power low index of
their energy distribution however we
don't know that the field is oriented in
this way we can image the polarization
pattern on the sky around Sagittarius a
star and from that in further
large-scale geometry of the magnetic
field in terms of expectations we expect
because of the circular orbit of the
material that is emitting the radiation
we would expect some feed lines to be
coherent on the scale you know of the
orbit the orbital radius but there
should also be a component due to
turbulence that adds sort of a random
orientation on small scales and we I
mean the event horizon telescope
hopefully will shed more light on exact
the exact geometry and compare it to
simulations yeah
for the tight collimation of the jet
right so there are various ideas that
were proposed 30 years ago for how to
produce jets and nowadays they can be
tested through numerical simulations mhd
simulations with magnetic fields the
general feature when you see these just
produced in numerical simulation is that
you need an accretion disk around the
black or the black hole has to have spin
usually and then the magnetic field
lines in the in the disk get wrapped
around the black hole as close to the
inner most stable circular orbit and
then some of the material is going along
feed lines that form a helical structure
like a tower rising above the black hole
and you see that in simulations and the
energy for the jet could come from two
sources either from the spin of the
black hole and this is a mechanism
proposed by blunt for dins Nyak and it's
called the blood falls night mechanism
where you basically spin down the black
hole and give the energy to to the jet
another source of energy is the disc
itself because the disc has material
orbiting around the black hole and you
can tap this rotational energy from the
material to the outflow and there has
been a debate in the literature as to
what is the ultimate source of energy it
looks like for rapidly spinning black
holes the spin of the black hole can do
the job quite nicely and you end up with
beautiful jets produced on the computer
that resemble the ones we see in nature